Hey everyone, I am here today with Catie who you may recognize from the now infamous double slit reaction video that I made
Caitie and I thought we'd have a bit of a discussion today about what science means to us and the way we're doing this is by
Typing in a phrase into Google. We've got a laptop here
The phrase you've chosen is what does science and there's a few results here
We're just going to run through them
Use it as a way to discuss I guess what science is and what it means to us. Exactly. Yeah, so let's get into it
So the first question is what does science mean? Or, it's the first result that comes up what the science mean?
so yeah, I guess these are questions you hear every day, but I think they're something I could have an opinion on as a scientist
What the science mean? I guess the definition for me of science is something that uses the scientific method like
that means making a hypothesis of something like an guess or an educated guess on how something is going to work and then
Testing that hypothesis maybe doing experiments
getting back to that either supports the hypothesis or helps you create a new one and sort of
Iterating through that method and that doesn't just apply to like something you would do in a lab with like chemicals in a lab coat
It's just an approach to the world like
scientifically looking at things making assumptions or hypotheses on how they work and seeing if the evidence
Supports that and if it does great and if it doesn't, changing your mind. to me, I'm from a non
Physics degree non science degree. I'm very much in the arts side
I think science is just life in general. So I think everything is science and it's like you look at something
Yeah
that's that science because if it weren't for that we wouldn't have or we wouldn't know as much as we do now.
And i think it's just amazing really and even like I know it's not necessarily what it just means to me but
Science is life
Yeah, I guess that's why I'm interested in hearing your perspective on these things from someone who maybe is more on the arts side of science
I think that's still a legitimate view of science and to hear that people see science as
Life, like that's it's good to know and to see how it's thought of, you know
Among  people because I know on my channel
I used to have a very niche audience of like mostly I was watched by other scientists and they would have a
Similar definition to me of what science was
but now I guess my reach is growing a bit and I want to make sure I'm including people and
Knowing what they think of science and yeah what it means to them
Yeah, and I feel like I've learnt so much from watching your channel like wow I didn't know that there we go.
Double-slit experiment that's one thing but even just by watching all of your videos. I was saying to Toby before that
One of my favorite videos is the Rapunzel hair one because I'm 100% into like Disney sort of stuff
And so the fact that you are able to then bring it something that's maybe not technically what people think of as science
I mean like hey it is. Yeah and here's how it is incorporated and here's it in a real life situation
Yeah, that's good to hear
Alright, so next one on our little list here
So what the science stand for
Not sure I quite understand what that means. Is it an acronym? I think I know what it means. Yes
It's an acronym it means let me follow the letters
Science can independently
educate nice
Children everywhere. I like it because it has science in the definition
That's why like, the best definitions are the ones that say the word in the definition
Yeah, I think we nailed that one. I think that's what it stands for
Maybe they can let us know in the comments
Yeah, what does why is science stand for? What other acronyms do you have?
I'm looking forward to some acrostic poems. Yeah
Right, what does science fiction mean?
I mean, it's another sort of weird question. What does science fiction mean well to me science fiction. I
Think of in terms of like popular books and movies and stuff where it's something. That's kind of
Sciencey but the science doesn't quite exist yet
So like really fast spaceship Star Wars Star Wars like things you could imagine being done with science
But we currently can't do one that aren't like widely available something. Yes. Yeah, I agree and I think
Whenever I think of science fiction, I think of Blade Runner because I did that at school
Yeah, and so now all of my perception of science fiction is blade runner
But I'm like, well one day it's gonna be like that and that's just science. Yeah, I thin k
my favorite science fiction
Movie is arrival. I've spoken about that in a video before I just love the concept. Yeah
I think that's me with interstellar. Yeah, I'm gonna say every time I watch it. I'm like well, yeah, my mind is gone
So I hear people talking about science fiction maybe being important to science in terms of like it inspires
science so like if the movie comes out and the director or whatever has a vision for some
New technology and how it's going to change our life and give us a new way of living
Science tends to work towards those things. Towards those technological innovations
So in a way it is like the apex of science like yeah, it can be what inspires the technology to catch up
Yeah
Definitely. Mu favourite thing about science fiction movies that are made a few decades ago is when they have like these amazing
Things and like it's gonna happen by 2000 and then be like, oh, not there yet, but they've got dreams and we all need them
yeah, and I think it still helps to drive the
Inspiring stuff forwards. Yeah, absolutely
All right. Here's a big one. What does science mean to you? I think we might have slightly different views on this
For me, what does science mean to me? It's
Science really does I guess define my life in a way because you know, I would consider myself a scientist
I've done a lot of years in
University and school learning science and basing my career around science and even this YouTube channel
I have it's based around talking about science and my life studying science
So it in a way it can be hard for me to separate science from my identity
Yeah, it's like that is you yeah, they're very woven together
And I guess I chose that because I was very interested in science
but science
To me isn't just a topic you choose to study like at school. It's almost like a religion like a set of beliefs
a philosophy of
looking at the world through these I guess scientific lenses and I
Guess I feel a lot of people turn to religion
to find a place of belonging and to find an explanation like
To find answers cuz everyone wonders like what are we what is life, you know the really big things
Those are not the questions we are going to be answering today
and to me I gained a satisfaction to
answering those questions from science. Yeah, and that was so much better than my answer is ever going to be
um
that was amazing
Which is why you do Sciences like you can tell how much of a passion that you have for it, which is so great
Mm-hmm, I think for me
science
again, when I say a science is life, science is everywhere
So to me, it's like technology. It's
growing and learning and I actually work at a science and arts museum, so I'm able to
Bring that every day into what I do and we get to teach kids that
from like five to fifteen and give them new opportunities that they might not get because of science and
Watching them discover things
Especially like with technology and with coding and even that side of science you can see them little minds. Yeah, and it's just
such a beautiful little thing to just get more people learning and learning and that in this is just rambling, but that like
Encouragement to learn and to continue learning I think is what science is and what it brings out in you a little bit
Yes, and also science is looking up at the sky and having your head explode because the universe is amazing
So I really like that answer I just from talking to you
I get the sense that to you science means a way of inspiring people. Yeah a way of improving their lives
and the way they look at the world. Yeah. Yes
So I think in a way we're saying the same thing yours is just definitely more eloquent
So that's our last question on there and I hope you got something out of our discussion
I really like talking about science and the philosophy of science. It's just something I really like to do and
Talking broadly to my friends about it. That's one of my favorite things
So thank you guys for watching go over and subscribe to Catie's channel
I'll put a link in the description and we're going to film a nother video for her channel. Also using some google themed
Games a google feud. Yes, so we're going to play a game called google feud
You'll know a little bit more about it if you head over to my channel
So pretty much you can pick a little category and Google will ask you a question or start a question for you
For example, why does sport or what does sport and then you have a few chances
You have three chances pretty much to get 10 of those answers. It's gonna be like, I don't know anything about sport
like why is sport the worst thing that's gonna be my answer. All right. Thank you guys